face à la crise sociale le gouvernement
va de renoncement en renoncement
le premier renoncement c'est l'équilibré
de nos finances publiques
et c'est pas un sujet comptable par
finances publiques on parle des finances
de tous les français
malgré une croissance française qui
résiste mieux compte tenu d'une moindre
exposition à l'économie mondiale vous
dégradez de 45% votre objectif de
réduction des déficits publics sur la
durée du quinquennat
l'écart avec nos voisins européens se
creuse en 2018 le déficit de la france
est supérieur de près de 2 points à
celui de la zone euro vous avez
abandonné votre objectif de réduction de
la dette publique de 5.2 piv vous avez
abandonné l'idée de baisser la dépense
structurelles de notre pays elle
repartira à la hausse dès cette année
quand on se compare monsieur le premier
ministre
on se désole le deuxième renoncement ce
sont les réformes indispensables
les propos du président de la république
sont très vagues et quand ces vagues
c'est qu'il y a du vague à l'âme
vous n'y croyez plus et vous ne croyez
plus à la réforme en profondeur de notre
pays
seulement à quelques ajustements vous
évitez soigneusement d'aborder le débat
sur l'âge de départ à la retraite
sacrifiant ainsi la parité unité
financière du système vous renoncez à
votre objectif de supprimer 120 mille
postes dans la fonction publique
condition indispensable de la réforme de
l'état
à chaque fois que le président de la
république prend la parole
cela coûte 10 milliards d'euros à la
france entre décembre et avril entre
décembre et avril
nous sommes à près de 20 milliards
d'euros de mesures nouvelles dont
financez vous distribuer de l'argent
public que vous n'avez pas vous créer du
pouvoir d'achat sur du sable
le financement de cette injection
massive de fonds publics repose sur deux
leviers qui n'en sont pas d'abord
l'augmentation de l'impôt sur les
sociétés et la suppression de niches
fiscales et ensuite le recours à
l'endettement mettant ainsi à
contribution les générations futures
cerise sur le gâteau un mois des
élections européennes vous à les
transmettre à la commission une
trajectoire de finances publiques et
rooney alors monsieur le premier
ministre
est ce cela pour vous là d'être européen
après la conférence du président de la
république et après votre séminaire
gouvernemental du flou toujours du flou
mais pas sur le dérapage des déficits
publics au moment où la croissance se
faibli vous avez fait le choix de
creuser le déficit
comme l'indiquait un ancien rapporteur
général de la cour des comptes interrogé
suite à vos annonces
le déficit public se dégrade et votre
politique budgétaire menacent la
cohérence de la zone euro à long terme
pourtant le candidat emmanuel macron le
disait lui même ne pas réduire nos
dépenses courantes et notre dette serait
irresponsable pour les générations à
venir
et il avait raison mais deux ans après
ces belles paroles
l'état dépense encore plus que sous la
présidence de françois hollande il faut
tout de même le faire et sans faire
d'économies structurelles
l'émotion n'est jamais bonne conseillère
surtout lorsqu elle s'empare des
puissants face aux flammes qui ont
ravagé notre dame
emmanuel macron s'est laissé envahir par
l'orgueil
à l'écouter il ne faudrait que cinq ans
pour restaurer la cathédrale et entendez
moi bien pour la rendre ouvrez les
guillemets encore plus belle huit cents
ans d'histoire n'ont pas suffi à aspirer
au président un peu plus de modestie
notre dame n'a nul besoin d'un concours
international ou d'un geste
architectural mais d'être rétabli dans
sa splendeur quasi millénaire
un travail qui requiert l'humilité des
premiers bâtisseurs le temps de la
réflexion et le concours des meilleurs
experts et artisans toute préoccupation
dont le président s'est malheureusement
détournée
ce qui nourrit de grandes craintes pour
l'avenir la france dispose par ailleurs
des meilleurs spécialistes de la
protection du patrimoine y compris dans
votre ministère
je m'interroge donc également sur le
concours international d'architecturé
envisagée pour reconstruire la flèche de
la cathédrale
prenons garde monsieur le ministre
qu'après avoir connu loutre âge des
flammes
l'intégrité de notre dame ne soit pas
mise à mal par des innovations visant à
la ronde selon l'expression même du
président de la république plus belle
encore les chiffres sont inquiétants la
délinquance a explosé en 2010 8 par
rapport à l'année 2010 est qui marquait
déjà une très forte hausse des actes
délictueux augmentation de la
délinquance c'est malaise croissant des
forces de l'ordre allant jusqu'aux susi
tirent leur source de la même cause a
une incapacité à prendre en compte les
besoins de ceux qui nous protège
le président de la république pendant sa
très longue intervention la semaine
dernière n'a pas fait allusion à la
question de la sécurité des français
monsieur le premier ministre la
responsabilité de cet échec
un combat votre gouvernement inutile de
me répondre que cette hausse est la
faute des gilets jaunes en 2017 il n'y
avait pas de gilet jaune inutile de me
répondre que cela vient de loin
l'augmentation de la délinquance ne peut
être considéré comme une fatalité
comptez vous monsieur le premier
ministre revoir la feuille de route des
ministères de l'intérieur et de la
justice afin de mettre un terme à la
croissance de l'insécurité dans notre
pays
les français attendent de vous monsieur
le ministre de l'intérieur fermeté et
efficacité au delà des postures des
résultats nos forces de l'ordre font
face avec professionnalisme endurance
discipline à des actes de violence sans
précédent par leur durée et leur
intensité monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur peuvent-elles compter sur
vous monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur
nos services de renseignement
connaissent depuis de nombreuses années
déjà les black blocks et autres
mouvances anarchistes
nous nous étonnons que vous n'ayez pas
encore réussi à mettre un terme à leurs
agissements
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur les
français peuvent-ils compter sur votre
efficacité et votre professionnalisme